(audience cheering)
- Ugh, how are you?
- I'm good, how are you doing?
- I'm so good.
- Great to see ya.
- I um, my sister, I can't
wait to call her after this,
she's gonna be so jealous.
(Darius laughs)
Yeah.
You don't know this but there's actually
this random thing that happened
and it was when you were
in Hootie & the Blowfish
and my family, they were
from North Carolina,
and they were at some
thing that you happened
to just stop by and be at,
it was just some house party?
- Uh huh.
- And I love these stories
because they don't get told enough,
but you were so cool to everyone there,
like you didn't act like, you know,
that you're Hootie & the Blowfish.
(Darius laughs)
Yeah you were like very cool!
Anyway, my sister was there, she's like,
"That dude's like, really
actually very cool."
Yeah, I just, we don't
spread those stories enough
so I wanted to spread that.
- [Darius] Thank you very much.
- You have two kids that live here, right?
- I got two that live in the city, yeah.
- Yeah, so you're Nashville
to New York a lot then.
- Yeah, I spend a lot of time in New York.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love it, do you?
- I do love it, but I'm way
too southern to live here.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I thought-
- So, but, uh-
- Okay wait, I thought that
too, right, 'cause I'm Texan,
but like, once you live
here, it's interesting
because it's almost like you
have these tiny little villages
that make up Manhattan.
- Yes, absolutely.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Yeah I lived there for two years.
- [Kelly] Oh you did!
- In 2000 and 2001, and that
was the first thing I said,
I walked in my apartment, I looked around
and I said, "Yeah, I'm way too
southern to be here, but uh-"
- [Kelly] Well, I will
say the apartments here,
they're closets.
- [Darius] Yes they are!
They are.
But I love them still. I love them.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I do too, the
energy is very, very cool.
- Oh, it's great.
- Yeah, and your two kids, two
girls, right, that live here?
- There's two, boy and
a girl that live here.
- [Kelly] Oh a boy and a girl!
- [Darius] My oldest lives in Nashville.
- [Kelly] Okay awesome!
Is your youngest just
now out of the house?
- Yeah, he's 18.
- Are you like, an empty nester?
- Are you liking it?
- Um...
- [Kelly] Oh that means, whoa!
- Nothing's really changed!
Nothing's really changed, 'cause I've been
on the road so much this year.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- [Darius] So it's like, been that,
but I miss them.
I get up here a lot.
You know, you miss seeing
them because they're,
you know, you've got kids,
they're your heart and soul.
- [Kelly] I know but they're 7 and 9
and I can't imagine them
being, like, out on their own,
like, doing stuff, that
terrifies me a little bit, yeah.
- [Darius] My son, in about
a year, grew about 8 inches,
went from about 5'8" to 6'4", so that was-
- Congratulations for him!
- [Darius] For him, but now
he thinks he can take me
and I keep letting him know, boy,
I got old man strength.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'll kill you, but uh-
- Yeah, but I love it.
I love my kids.
- [Kelly] Experience,
yeah, I have experience,
I will take you down.
- Exactly!
- I love it.
So, Halloween with kids, do
you, whenever they were younger,
this is my first
Halloween here and my boy,
it's his favorite holiday.
My girl loves Christmas
most but he loves Halloween
and so we really get into costumes.
Did y'all do that when they were younger?
- We did, we got costumes every year,
they dressed up as something.
My favorite costume ever
was, my son dressed up as
Darth Vader and I dressed
up as Luke Skywalker
and I think he was 6,
and he walked around,
at every door he'd go, "I'm his father."
It was very funny.
- Oh my god!
- [Darius] It was vary funny.
- Does he have a voice like yours?
'Cause your voice is so distinct.
- He's got a good voice,
it's not like mine so much,
but he's got a great voice.
- Yeah, I just mean, it's
like, yeah, your rasp,
it's just so,
- Yeah.
- It's so awesome.
You just said, "Yeah. Yeah."
- I try.
- I try, I sometimes like when I'm sick
because that's when my rasp
comes out and I'm singing,
I like, but other than that,
it's just really annoying and high.
- [Darius] You have one of
those voices for all time.
- [Kelly] Oh, you're very nice.
- Your voice is unbelievable. Absolutely.
(audience cheering)
- I love it though 'cause
your voice is so distinct,
but whenever you were
going around with him,
did you have a favorite candy?
'Cause this is what I do,
I tell my kids they can have
one, like, a night, right?
And I don't collect candy, but I kinda do,
because when they go to
bed, I take some of theirs.
- [Darius] Yeah, this is
a very unpopular thing
but I'm a candy corn guy.
I love candy corn.
- [Kelly] No, that's classic!
- I love it.
- Yeah, candy corn is classic.
I'm a Reese's Cup girl,
not that mini stuff.
(audience cheering)
Not the mini.
- Me too, I don't like the minis!
- The ratio's off with the
chocolate and the peanut butter.
Get outta here with that.
- I like the minis, and when
you go to somebody's house
and they've got minis, like,
I like to be the neighbor,
like, I've got the big chocolate bars.
"I'm going to Mr. Rucker's house!"
- [Kelly] Oh my god, so we were poor kids,
and that's what we'd do,
they'd take us, like, other neighborhoods.
We'd go to the neighborhoods
with all the rich people!
- We would too!
- We'd be like, "Nah, you get like,
a full Butterfinger there!"
It was like, you wanna go there!
- Absolutely! We did the same thing.
- We did not trick-or-treat
in my neighborhood.
- Oh, we did that too.
- You did?
Oh yeah, we didn't have
much in our neighborhood.
But do you believe in
like, the supernatural,
speaking of like, Halloween,
do you believe in ghosts
and stuff like that?
- I do.
- I don't not believe, but I haven't had,
like, a real experience.
- [Darius] I was in
college, and me and Dean,
who plays bass in Hootie,
we moved into this place
and we just a bunch of beds
from my house that were around,
and I had my grandmother's bed.
- Yeah.
- [Darius] My grandmother
had died and I'm sitting,
I wake up, 3 o'clock one morning
and I look at the edge of my bed,
my grandmother's sitting there.
- Oh!
- [Darius] And she's
sitting there, and I sit up,
I wipe my eyes, and I go, "Wow!"
and she's still sitting
there, and I get up
and I run out of my bed
and I run to Dean's room.
I was like, "Dean! My
grandmother's ghost is in my room,
can I sleep in your bed?"
He went, "No!"
(Darius and audience laughing)
- Not there for you at all?
- [Darius] No!
I went on the couch. Yeah.
- You're a grown man,
go back to your room!
- Exactly!
- I know, but does it
scare you, or did it-
That's kind of cool!
- I would like to see a ghost!
- [Darius] It's scary a little.
But I believe in that stuff, big time.
- [Kelly] I don't not believe in it,
I just don't see it.
They don't like me, or, I don't know.
They don't show themselves to me.
They're like, "That one's too much."
I have to ask you this
because when I go back and
look at stuff in the beginning,
it, kind of, I cringe a little.
And it's the 30th
anniversary, it's coming up,
of the first record of
Hootie & the Blowfish.
When you listen to that, are
you like me, do you cringe
or do you just still love it and are...
- [Darius] I don't think I've
listened to Cracked Rear View
in 30 years.
- [Kelly] Oh really?
You know why, though?
People, yeah, it's not
'cause you don't like it,
it's because you listen to
it so much while doing it.
- [Darius] So much while
making it, exactly!
When you're making a record,
you listen to it every day,
all day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You get in the car and
you're listening to it.
And once you make it and it comes out,
I bet I haven't listened
to it in 30 years.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you have
to kind of let it go
unless you're at, like, a show doing it.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, singing it.
- But I'm gonna put it on here soon,
'cause 30 years is a long time.
- [Kelly] 30 years is incredible!
- I know, can you believe it?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Crazy.
- [Kelly] What a blessing.
- Yeah, it's been great.
- [Kelly] 'Cause not everybody
has that kind of longevity.
- [Darius] It's been crazy.
- In this industry.
- [Darius] Yeah.
- Yeah!
Well, you got a great voice, so.
- Well, thank you.
Thank you very much.
- [Kelly] When did you realize,
'cause a lot of us sing,
when did you realize like,
I don't feel, I feel like I'm a chameleon,
I can go in different genres,
but I don't have like,
a distinct sound, like a
you, or like an Annie Lennox,
or Bono, or, there's certain voices
that have this, like,
certain distinct sound.
When did you realize,
like, yours was special?
- When I was, like, 5.
- [Kelly] 'Cause your voice,
were you a man when you were 5?
Were you like, "What's up, mom?"
Like, you were like-
- It wasn't this deep, but you know,
I can still sing those
Al Green songs up high.
- Oh my god!
- When we were 5, my mom
would tell me all the time,
"You gotta do this for a living."
- [Kelly] Oh wow!
- This is something special.
- [Kelly] So you had support
right from the beginning?
- From the beginning.
Yeah.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- My mom was behind me
from the very beginning.
She knew I was gonna be big
before I ever thought about it.
- Wow!
- [Darius] Yeah.
- All right, we'll call her Nostradamus.
(Darius laughing)
So, did you ever, were you
that guy that used your voice
for like, 'cause I feel
like you got a lot of ladies
with that voice.
(Darius laughing)
You know what I'm saying?
Like, I'm the kind of person,
I don't leave voicemails
'cause I sound annoying.
My talking voice is very different,
but yours is like, all sexy,
did you get a lot of ladies
'cause of that?
(Darius stammering)
That means yes!
- It didn't hurt!
- [Kelly] That means yes!
- It didn't hurt.
It didn't hurt.
I have this story about one time,
I guess I was a freshman in college,
I met this girl, she was
older, she was a junior,
and we'd talk in the bar and we'd hang out
for a little while and
one night, I'm drunk,
and she's living on the first floor
of this apartment
building, and I go outside
and I'm singing Billy Joel songs.
- [Kelly] You're John Cusack!
- Outside her window.
- [Kelly] Just outside the window?
- Yeah, outside her window.
She came out and she
laughed, and she led me in
and we had a beer.
I'll leave it at that.
Yeah, so we had a beer.
(Darius and audience laughing)
- They had a beer.
- Yeah, we had a beer.
- Congratulations on that beer.
- That was good.
- I would work that angle too
if I had that kind of voice.
I'd be like, "Yes, ladies!"
Did you, a lot of us too,
I always run into musicians
and I feel like we all
grew up singing in church.
Did you grow up singing in church?
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, me too.
- Amazing Grace was, you know,
♪ Amazing grace ♪
♪ How sweet the sound ♪
♪ That saved a wretch like me ♪
That was my song!
- Yes!
- [Darius] I love that song.
- We all have a go-to.
Mine was His Eye Is On The Sparrow.
- [Darius] Oh, absolutely!
- I love Amazing Grace, but
His Eye Is On The Sparrow,
I think 'cause I saw Sister
Act when I was a little kid,
and I was like, "I wanna be Lauryn Hill!"
I was like, yeah, I loved them.
I thought it was so good.
But those songs, I feel like,
I feel like I sing differently
because I have that
background, you almost,
you know there's a bigger
purpose for all of us
and it's bigger than you.
And when that's instilled
in you at such a young age,
I think spiritual people sing differently.
- I agree.
- [Kelly] Yeah, whatever your
belief is, I just mean like,
I feel like if you believe
in something bigger than you,
and outside of yourself,
it's a different sound
that comes from you.
- [Darius] I agree.
I think you sing from your soul.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You sing from as far in
the depths of your soul
as you can and I think
that creates something really special.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it's
almost like you're able
to put your ego aside, 'cause
we're told at a very young age
like, it's not for you, it's for the Lord.
It's not for you, it's
for something bigger.
- [Darius] Exactly.
- I love that you just sang on my show.
I was like, "alright, alright!"
I heard that, too, I love Ed Sheeran,
I got to work with him on The Voice,
and you did a song with him, right?
- We did, I did.
I went to, I've known Ed for
years and I went to England
to write with him and
when I first sat down,
we were writing the song, and he asks me
who my first love was.
And I said it was my fifth
grade girlfriend, Sarah.
And he asked me these million questions
and then at the end of
the session, he's like,
"Hey, I got one more song,
let's write the song about Sarah."
And I said, you want to write a song
about my fifth grade girlfriend?
I haven't talked to her in 45 years!
And you wanna talk-
and we wrote a song called Sarah
about my fifth grade girlfriend.
- You wanna know why I think
that's such a great idea?
We always, I feel like
adults always say like,
"Oh, they're children,
what do they know of love?"
Or, "What do they know of this?"
And I'm like, I think,
children, they're not jaded yet.
- Oh, exactly.
- I think that kids feel everything.
I never tell my kids when they come home,
they're 7 and 9, but
they already are like,
"Oh, I love him."
And I'm like, "I truly
believe you probably do
with your whole heart!"
I'm like, you know, "You
probably gonna change your mind,
but like, I'm just gonna let you know."
But yeah, I just think
it's such a pure thing
and there's no other
experience jading that.
- Yes, I agree.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I agree.
I love the song.
Ed's such a great songwriter.
- [Kelly] I have to ask you this too
because this album art is beautiful.
This your momma?
- That's my mom.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, what was the idea,
why did you end up using this picture?
- [Darius] Well, that's her nursing school
graduation picture, she
was 24 in that picture
and all of our family has
that picture up on their wall.
And, you know, my mom
was so special to me.
She was such a great human being.
She was, like I said, she
was my biggest supporter,
my biggest fan.
When I decided to name
the record Carolyn's Boy,
I knew it was gonna be that picture.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- It's a great picture.
- I love that.
I'm like that when I write
too, I have imagery going,
I have to like almost
paint a picture in my head
while I'm doing it.
- [Darius] Oh, me too.
- Yeah.
- [Darius] Every song I write,
there's a video in my head.
- [Kelly] Me too!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay I thought I was weird.
- You are, but-
- Yeah!
(Darius and audience laughing)
You are, but I am too.
What do you feel like the best lesson,
other than her being so supportive,
I imagine you're like that with your kids
because you were taught
that from a young age,
but what do you think the biggest lesson
you got from her was?
- [Darius] Oh, believe in yourself.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause we grew up in a
really poor neighborhood
with not much and, you
know, there was no reason
for me to believe that I was
gonna be here and make it
but she always instilled
in me, believe in yourself,
you can do whatever you want.
I instill that in my
kids and I believe it.
- That's incredible.
'Cause not all parents do that,
you know what I'm saying?
- [Darius] Definitely not.
I know.
When I was a kid, she instilled in us
that you help people, not
people that are less fortunate,
you help people that need help.
I tell the story about my
brother, I guess I was 10.
Probably not 10, I was probably 7 or 8,
my brother was 14 and we had this couple
that lived in our neighborhood
and the husband was in the navy.
- Uh huh.
- [Darius] And so, he
went away on the ship,
and the yard was growing
up and my brother went over
and cut her grass, and she gave him $10.
And he came home bragging
about the $10 he got,
and my mom whooped his butt and told him,
"You take that $10 back down
and you give it back to her
because we don't help people for money,
we help people to help people."
And that was just something
she instilled in us.
- [Kelly] Oh wow!
- Yeah.
- You got a great mom!
Wow.
Very lucky.
Well, we have a little surprise for you
and I was very excited
to be able to do this.
- [Darius] Do you?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You don't know, he really
doesn't know about it.
This is not TV, this is real.
For your many, many charitable
efforts over the years
and for helping those who need help,
CMA is actually honoring you
as Humanitarian of the Year.
- Wow!
- You got your trophy and everything!
- Oh my goodness!
(audience cheering)
Wow!
- I'm so excited!
- That's awesome!
Wow.
Wow!
I really did not know that!
- I know!
I was like, "No, he really doesn't know!"
- I did not know that.
- Alright, well, let's do another break.
Darius' latest album is
called Carolyn's Boy,
it's out right now,
y'all gotta check it out
and he's also designed
his own line of NFL gear
which is super cool, rad,
which is available in stores
and online, so y'all gotta check that out.